yeah is rewind time you know if I could
control rewind I would want it to be an
actual rewind
[Music]
No
three one time everybody
[Music]
some perfectly Burger King but lettuce
the last thing you want in your burger
King burger is someone's bro
[Music]
we're forgetting something
I think we should read what the comments
actually says three one time seriously
you said that I'm gonna copy strike this
bad kid for you on before they're gone
[Music]
who was marshmallow attention all ethics
for tonight gamer ninja he's in grave
danger
and he needs your help hey what is this
one second for Wisconsin
[Music]
is this what you wanted now then shapiro
wants to know my location okay that was
epic
next meme
[Music]
although my body is very limited my mind
is free to explore the universe if you
have an idea that you genuinely think is
good don't let some idiot talk you out
of it
a special thank you to all of you my
dear meme friends thank you so much
now concentrate on how it makes you feel
and let your hand drift across the
canvas one time
[Music]
ah that's hot ah that's